it's time for our scene an unseen
segment where we expose what's really
behind the big cultural stories of the
day all right we kick off today's
edition with something so ridiculous
that it has to be seen to believe this
is a candidate for Congress making a
complete buffoon of himself and a
desperate bid for votes here to Phyllis
and Fox News contributor off to the
author of the New York Times bestselling
author of the will Wilder series Raymond
Arroyo all right who is this guy his
name is Levi Tillman he's a Democrat
from Colorado
he feels Congress has been talking over
each other in regard to school safety
Hathi the Trump administration would
like to arm teachers Tillman has a
different approach and he demonstrates
it empowers schools and teachers with
non-lethal self-defense tools like this
can of pepper spray trust me this will
stop anyone in their tracks and now I
just can't see anything
Wow that's intense for less than $1 per
person in the US we can have a secured
canister of pepper spray in every
classroom in America it's just the ad is
like lava in your eyes this man I mean
thank God he's not a wild game advocate
he'd be setting off bear traps and
bleeding all over so he looks like he
was waterboarding himself I'm like what
is it I mean at the end of it I wanted
to spray myself with pepper spray just
so I didn't have to watch I think we
should call him and produce a new show
candidate versus the world he could just
do stunts like this protest by breathing
in carbon monoxide he could drink toilet
and they say a certain type of black
spider issues on the endangered species
so I'm living with them here the hell
are here's the big question how can you
trust the judgment of a man who does
Canada's a Canada Democratic candidate
for a House seat in Colorado disturbing
all right what is going on with the
Bishop of Tucson well the Catholic
Bishops are meeting this week in Florida
and they lamented the Trump
administration's new Asylum rules
particularly those separating children
from families entering the country
illegally now at one point the Bishop of
Tucson Arizona as you mentioned Edward
Wyson burger seemed to morally equate
those enforcing the border with people
committing abortions he's speaking here
about border security that takes the
part in separating families watch in
light of the canonical penalties that
are there for life issues I'm simply
asking the question if perhaps our
canonical Affairs Committee could give
recommendations at least to those of us
who are border bishops on the
possibility of canonical penalties for
Catholics who are involved in this for
the salvation of these people's souls
maybe it's time for us to look at
canonical penalties maybe it's time for
you to read canon law well what does he
mean rescinding Communion and the
sacraments they do that for people do
that for politicians that advocate for
abortion I got a lunch this afternoon
from some ice and border security guys I
said when
Pelosi Biden and Schwarzenegger get
their letters of excommunication then
you can worry but remember the Catholic
catechism says those new to an adoptive
country must respect the laws that the
contrary none of us want families
divided I think it's an awful thing but
we have to come up with policies that
don't incentivize people to send their
children alone across the border that's
what's happening now but look people of
faith Catholics they should be
advocating for family unity in their
home country and you do it do it legally
but and orderly you walk across the
border illegally it's not gonna work for
you all right now what does God look
like what does God look like you know 60
seconds we noted North Carolina did a
study 511 Americans this is what they
think God looks like that looks like one
of the guys in the control room in New
York that look like it's Nick Robertson
he's basically a nice white guy what the
researchers found is in a cupid project
their image and their beliefs on to
their image of God now I thought what
would we how would we define God so I
came up with my own images however my
doubt is what I think I might look like
and Frank Sinatra and John Huston in the
greatest story what Frank Sinatra I want
a God that sings well so now you had
your pics who were my Pixar Burt
Lancaster and Charlton Heston which is
really good but Charlie has tune plays
Moses there and of course it's like God
before God that seems like God God can't
Lal I think God can't look like the kid
in the Apple commercial like the Mac
versus PC I don't that's who's the guy
that's like a millennial thing right
he's good God has skinny jeans a man
Bible and he's a SOI boy God's a SOI boy
I don't think they don't want to God
with some Authority and gravitas and a
father but I think we can both agree God
does not look like this these two Jorge
Bernal they played him to greater Morgan
Freeman I never bought either of those
not Morgan Freeman is God
wow that's a good boy just sound like
God George Burns mom is hilarious but
you don't want God to sound like no God
doesn't smoke absolutely no I hope no
all right not where I'm good not the God
I want to see no no no way no flames
we hope try for us